société générale
et nous doter mara qui dans la terreur
la bande à bonnot mis les voiles
portant le sac du quart sont payés dans
la 2 duo moutons qui cache et les
voleurs
d'un veut compter les gros billets et
les valeurs avec raymond la science les
bandits en notant
les peupliers
misérable
s'éloigner le bruit sans moteur quand ap
ap les coupables
juillet à toute allure
cinq années sur les routes de france
iront des légendes art
et par leurs trousses et es8 et jour en
allah en casquette à visière
elle est vendue en auto
et pour nous
voilà 6
on peut dérouler vite se ranger
voiture
sur place la maison
a choisi avec ses complices
on est dans ça chante
tout paris à iba avis entre un moyen en
train
avec des fusils les pistes les et des
gourdins hurlant des balcons les bandits
en notant c'était
la bande à bonn
un auto main
tragique destin
pour la dernière course
plus dans le fourgon la pente
abo